[Music]
one of the epiphanies for me in the last
very recent year or two hmm has been
looking at my coping mechanisms very
differently and what I mean by that is
for a very long time I had certain
behaviors certain defaults that I hated
which of course means I'm hating a part
of myself that's right and that included
anger rage responses yeah use of
stimulants you name it I a close friend
of mine who is a therapist but I've
never I've never engaged him as a
therapist and there's certainly plenty
of bad therapists out there which i
think is a separate topic nonetheless he
was helping and I'm sure we'll get back
to this but in preparation for a very
controlled supervised psychedelic
experience he was helping another friend
of ours mm-hmm prepare this is with MDMA
this is with ayahuasca today Iowa's
cocaine and this this person had a
number of addictions and she hated these
addictions and she said I hate these I
realized they're they're terrible
they've they've ruined my life they're
ruining my life and it was all a
negative relationship to these behaviors
and he said did these ever serve you did
these ever help what did these do for
you exactly and she and she described
how they helped her cope with very
difficult circumstances early on and he
said perhaps what you should do
as an exercise and what we can do is for
you to effectively thank those behavior
house for the role they played and for
the necessity they filled and to then
recognize you know thank them for their
duty effectively but to let them go
because they're no longer needed and
that was a huge eye-opener for me and I
began to this is coinciding with a
number of things and I want to take us
off the
but began to use something called
loving-kindness meditation or Metta my
Metta m ET ta meditation which I was
introduced to by gentleman from Google
actually or formerly Google chade-meng
tan and then also jack Kornfield who
really reiterated for me of course but I
never applied it to myself I always
applied this loving-kindness meditation
to other people players and what was
recommended is that I apply that
loving-kindness to these to the younger
Tim to the other versions of Tim who had
these behaviors that I had grown to hate
and resent and to actually thank them
for the role they played for instance
that rage that anger was the fuel that
got me out of Long Island and where I
grew up there a lot of serious drug
issues particularly with opiates my best
friend died of fentanyl many of my
friends are addicted to opiates who I
grew up with many have died and I got
out because I was angry in part I think
that was the fuel but that fuel ended up
over the long term being very corrosive
but to in a way to reconcile myself with
that I had to stop resenting it and I
suppose that's maybe more of a
confession than a question but your
comment brought it to mind and maybe as
a segue I just love to hear and we can
take it anywhere we want of course but
once you have shifted the focus from why
the addiction to why the pain and you
start to work with someone what
approaches have you found to help what
tools well so I very much salud your
friends approach it's exactly what the
approach I would take myself and I call
it compassionate inquiry so inquiry in a
compassionate way now why did I do this
but hmm why did I do this right the
first one is not a question it's a
statement it's a self condemnation the
second one is a question hmm wonder why
I did this ah it's with my pain and so
what your friend said that it served you
so thank it loved it but let go of it is
absolutely right I call it the stupid
friend
the stupid founders is the one who
helped you in a particular way at a
certain time but it can't learn that
that way doesn't function anymore right
that instead of helping now it's hurting
so it's a friend because it's really
trying to help but it's stupid because
it's not learning that you no longer
that three year older that's five year
although that's fifteen year old you
know so this not this leads to the the
question of trauma because it's one
thing to recognize that all this
originates in shotted pain it's quite
another to transform that pain and for
that we have to understand what trauma
is so people often think that trauma is
what happens to you so trauma is a
divorce when you were small and your
parents fighting trauma is your mother's
depression trauma as your father's
alcoholism trauma is your parents
argumentation traumas physical or sexual
abuse or some loss those aren't the
traumas those are traumatic but the
trauma is not what happens to you the
traumas what happens inside you and as a
result of these traumatic events what
happens inside you is yet you get
disconnected from your emotions and you
disconnected from your body and you have
difficulty being in the present moment
and you develop a negative view of your
world and a negative view of yourself
and a defensive view of other people and
these perspectives keep showing up in
your life in the present because they're
the stupid friends and so the issue is
not just to recognize what happened at
ten fifteen thirty however many years
ago but to actually recognize their
manifestations in the present moment and
to transcend them and already do that by
reconnecting with yourself by restoring
the connection with your body primarily
and with your emotions that you lost and
once you do when you found these things
again then you have what we call
recovery because what does it mean to
recover something it means to find it
again so what is it that people find
when they recover they find themselves
and the loss of self is the essence of
trauma so the real purpose of
of addiction treatment mental health
treatment any kind of healing is
reconnection
you